the Scorpion is a multi-mission is our
strike airplane that was designed to be
very effective and very affordable the
goal was to create a very mission
relevant aircraft for today's security
environment that is below 20 million
dollars in acquisition costs and below
three thousand dollars an hour to
operate
in a classic DoD acquisition program
they can spend up to ten years just
developing and fielding an aircraft and
we've done it and less than two the
Scorpion is primarily manufactured out
of composite material we chose that
because it would be good for corrosion
resistance and fatigue life also help
keep the weight and the cost down we
kept the construction of the Scorpion
secret really to maintain competitive
advantage the most unique feature is the
two tails you see can it out and that's
for dynamic and low-speed stability the
engines come out of business jets that
are all over the world and twing as
three hard points for carriage of
weapons and or fuel tanks or other
stores
the market potential is very good we are
well beyond initial discussions with a
potential launch customer and the
interest we have into discussions we're
having so far we think we hit the market
correctly